feels as if MPs are kind of increasingly
flexing their parliamentary muscles lots
of talk about more amendments next week
potentially suspending the article 50
process trying to block no deal and can
you just explain what's happening and do
you think MPs will be able to take no
deal off the table well I think you're
right to say that what happens when you
have a hung parliament is that power
does pass from from government for the
executive to Parliament and that's what
we are seeing play out I think there was
a frustration in Parliament that we
haven't had a chance until last Tuesday
to vote on the draft agreement and then
potentially on other options too so the
Prime Minister tomorrow is going to as I
understand it make a statement but put
down a motion which is going to say
there'll be further debate about next
steps on January the 29th and it's that
motion that can be amended and there's a
variety of different groups of MPs who
will put motions Dowell or amendments to
that motion down but I think it's very
clear that there is no majority in
parliament for a No Deal outcome and so
that's going to be one of the critical
things I think it's important to have
sort of Paul come these things apart so
that's the first thing and I'm working
with a cross-party group of MPs and if
that Cooper a Hilary Ben but also Nick
Bowles novelette one of my own party as
well as Norman lamb to put down a piece
of legislation because it is right that
if you want to stop a No Deal stop the
UK crashing out sliding out on 29th of
March of this year then the law does
need to be changed and so are very short
bill will say that if the Prime Minister
can't get an agreement approved by the
House of Commons by the end of February
then the government will need to ask
Brussels or to apply and to say we
wanted to extend article 50 we put in a
suggested date but of course all of this
is debatable and amendable by the House
of Commons and then there are other MPs
other groups who will be seeking to do
we think something similar I haven't
seen although some amendments or things
are going to be put down but you're
right so there's that process and then
of course as a process how do you build
a cross-party consensus towards an
agreement that can get a majority in the
House of Commons and that's where ideas
about whether it's Norway
or something else did you say around
single market customers Union that's
where that comes in I'm quite fascinated
and by the concept of all these MPs from
different parties working together I
mean how do you do it how do you have
those conversations is there a what's
that group I think
yes whatsapp has signed up a lot of MPs
and I think what you've seen those most
of the last two and a half years has
been people I was coming working across
party lines often for the first time so
so you know brexit started off as being
pretty party political it was down to
the conservative government that had
granted the referendum it was a
Conservative government who were going
to put in place a way of delivering on
the result but I think particular after
2017 general election the result there
it became very clear that of course
people were going to need to work cross
party lines in order to find a an
agreement and it's interesting that many
of us who are working across party are
chairs of select committees which which
always operate on a cross-party basis
try to operate by unanimity so we have
seen how cross party working can provide
positive results in a way forward and so
I think that's why you see as I say it
made the chair set committees in that in
that process and actually I think the
brexit shouldn't be a party political
issue because we've all got in our
parties people who voted leave people
who voted remain and many people
represent constituencies where the
results were pretty close or they might
have a particular view but the
constituency voted another way and
that's what I think all MPs are trying
to find a way forward to get to a place
where I think most people want there to
be an agreement in place for leaving but
of course there's a group of people in
the House of Commons who don't want that
to happen they would like to have
another vote across the country where
remain would be an option that's not
something that I agree with okay and
we've we spoke a bit about the
amendments that you're working on I just
want to really try and pin you down on
the Dominic Greve amendment and that has
caused a lot of concern actually among
some men who's there this morning
there's been quite a lot of debate about
it this idea that there could be
legislation to so
spend article 50 is that something that
you would support well as I say the bill
that I put my name to does say that if
the government can't get an agreement in
place then the Minister would have to
apply to say to Brussels right wewe need
to suspend article 50 for a period of
time so that we can build a consensus
and get ourselves you know more prepared
for for exit and so that's something
that I will be support okay and what I
don't know is whether Dominic's
amendment goes further than that and
there is talk obviously about whether
and I think I think Ken Clark and others
have said well perhaps article 50 should
be revoked and um you know look I'm a
strong former remain campaigner but
where I do agree with dom rave and i
heard part of his interview is that i
think people do want us to get on with
this I do think that actually we had a
vote and that actually is important that
the UK is going to leave the EU we're
going to leave the political
institutions but there are ways to do it
in an orderly fashion to mitigate the
economic damage and that's what I'm
interested in doing I mean it feels as
if Parman is really trying to wrestle
control of this process almost as if
there are two governments going on in
Parliament at the minute and some of the
things that are being proposed this idea
for example that MPs could have
introduced motions that would take
precedence over government business for
some people this will sound a bit like a
coup is it well I think ISM as other MPs
said it's a strange sort of coup that
starts with a whole bunch of
democratically elected members of
parliament and and this is a I mean is
unprecedented for backbenchers business
to take precedence over government
business but it is very much confined to
one particular issue brexit and it's to
my immense regret that unfortunately
brexit appears to be the only thing that
we're able to discuss at the moment of
course it's important but I think many
people watching this are desperate for
their politicians and government to talk
about other issues and frankly I think
the MPs are also very keen to talk about
other issues many of which you know very
challenging many of which led to the
brexit result in 2016 anyway and so now
I think the what this is is M piece
on this particular issue we think there
is a different way forward we
particularly want to make sure there is
not a no deal outcome to brexit but the
government will carry on a government
will carry on governing and I have
ministers in other departments doing
doing other things so so now I think
described it as a as a coup is overblown
and we talked a lot about process I'm
keen to talk about the kind of brexit
that you are supporting this idea of
staying close to the single market and
in a potentially in the customs union
let's get real there's no way the EU
would allow that without the UK also
accepting free movement of people that
is right isn't it let's just admit it
well I think your that is common market
2.0 which is the option that I am
supporting if you would be part of after
part of the single market then yes
freedom of movement comes with that but
there are mechanisms and there are ways
to apply for there to be control and
actually and I think that the British
public have got a far more nuanced
understanding and interest in
immigration that may read wrong reddit
for as Theresa may read it right Prime
Minister well I think the Prime Minister
given her Home Secretary background has
always said that freedom of movement is
is important what people want there's no
doubt people voted some people voted in
2016 to leave the EU because of concerns
around immigration but there are lots
and lots of controls on immigration
who's coming here how long they're
coming here for why they're coming here
that are actually UK governments over
the years could have exercised much much
more than they chose to and actually
Sajid Javid plans on immigration begin
to take the UK in that direction if you
go to about the EU countries as
somebody's gonna live there for you know
six months a couple of years whatever
people have to register they have to
tell the local whether its police forces
or others that they're that they're
there and everything else we don't do
nearly enough of that in the UK and
that's the feedback I get from my
constituents it's about controls about
knowing who's here it's not about saying
we don't want people from overseas to
come and work in our NHS or work in our
University and I'm sitting here in
Loughborough big International
University big manufacturers nearby who
rely on people coming bringing their
talents from overseas
paying taxes here that that's not I
think that's something that people say
we must stop all of that but people do
want there to be control we could have
that control but we could still be part
of this Common Market 2.0 arrangement
now this week Theresa May suffered a
historic defeat the worst that any
sitting government has ever experienced
it's quite astonishing really and yet
unless I've missed something she doesn't
seem to have given any ground at all
when it comes to her plans for brexit
are you worried that the Prime Minister
isn't listening well I think the Prime
Minister is listening I was one of the
MPs who went to see her on Thursday and
there were meetings held with and
Conservative MPs opposition MPs and I
think the Prime Minister is in I think
the government is an incredibly
difficult position and I voted and other
prime ministers agreement on Tuesday and
I am stunned by people who have
campaigned off for friends of mine
who've campaigned for decades to get the
UK out of the EU who then didn't vote
for the agreement on on Tuesday but now
we are we're where we are I think trying
to find a way forward whether it is
finding a cross-party consensus in
Parliament whether it is seeing whether
the EU is able to give any more ground
which seems unlikely but look I'm not
privy to those negotiations it's a very
difficult decision for the prime
minister to make we're going to find out
more I think this week and certainly
next week about the prime minister's
plan B and then I think we'll all have
to make decisions MPs about what
snatched interest because ultimately
what people really want is stability and
certainty to know where they're going to
go what's going to happen on the 29th of
March you haven't always had the easiest
relationship with Teresa mate I think
one of the first acts she did when she
became prime minister was to sack you
and yet you have actually been one of
the few MPs to stand up in the House of
Commons and support what some of what
she's been trying to do do you think
Teresa mayor's suffered from a failure
to make enough friends when she was all
powerful because now is a time when she
really needs them look I think perhaps
that some that there is if there is a
fair point in there but equally I think
that however many friends
Prime Minister has you know when people
have a difficulty with something that
any Prime Minister is proposing and
unfortunately a friendship doesn't
always count and people will go with
what they think is right in in national
trust but I'm not no doubt that that's
how MPs are voting but ultimately I
think also we need to have a consensus
we need to move forward again I think
Don made a point about moving forward in
after March that is important and and I
hope that the Prime Minister actually
I've seen her she has been open to
discussions open to explain the deal and
everything else but there's a lot more
talking that is going to be needed to
get this over the line